welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video are
breaking down 2001 A Space Odyssey
[Music]
[Applause]
CA this Stanley Cooper classic is
arguably one of the most influential
films of all time perfecting its special
effects to tell a space age Adventure
across the Stars it's incredible how
much at this movie changed how sci-fi
was put to screen whether it's Star Wars
Star Trek June alien the abyss
Interstellar or whatever sci-fi film you
can think of all of them in some way of
taking elements of this in order to
craft their worlds the space travel
alone I should in how we imagine vessels
to move across the endless void and had
this never been made then we'd likely
see things portrayed slightly
differently every time I think about
planets in space I'm normally playing
the Richard Strauss song in my head and
it create the idea of it being like an
opera it's crazy to think that this was
released a year before man ever went to
the moon and it's insane to see a scene
where humans do it before we ever arrive
there this is of course in spite a lot
of conspiracy theories like Stanley
Kubrick directed the moon landing but we
see them walk around completely normal
here whereas the Apollo missions reveal
that the moon had less of gravity beyond
that though it predicted a hell of a lot
of things correctly about our future
whether it's the monolith being
something that's now commonplace in
phone design the evolution of AI in the
form of Hal a how space travels heading
towards commercialization this movie may
end up still being relevant a hundred
years from now just making the AI a
helpful entity that eventually turns bad
is something so many sci-fi stories have
adapted and even now Hal Still Remains
as the epitome of the genre but why does
it all work so well and why is this
movie still being talked about almost 60
years later it's rather difficult to
Define well that's what we're going to
be discussing in this video and
throughout it we'll be breaking down the
kubricking classic to discuss all the
elements that make it a masterpiece if
you enjoy the video please hit the
thumbs up button and with that out of
the way let's get into 2001. I'm sorry
Dave
I'm afraid I can't do that I like a lot
of Stanley Kubrick's work 2001 A Space
Odyssey was actually based on a book I'm
pretty sure most of his movies were
built off the back of books and that's
with only Killers kissing fear and
desire being fully original now what
Kubrick tended to do was pick and choose
the elements of a story that he liked
and these would then Inspire him to
build upon things with his own story
that's of course seen most notably in
The Shining and this movie actually
differs highly from its source material
based on Arthur C Clarke's as Sentinel
they saw a scientist named Wilson coming
across a mysterious pyramid placed on
the moon surrounded by a shield it takes
Humanity 20 years to pass through this
and they had to do it by harnessing
atomic energy destroying the shield they
also shatter the pyramid which is when
they discover its Origins are alien in
nature naming the structure The Sentinel
they discover it's been broadcasting a
signal into space that upon its
destruction will signal humans of
mastered space travel in the end Wilson
believes this will signal to its
creators that Earth now has an
intelligent life form on it and that the
aliens will soon start to look towards
our planet now Clark and Kubrick work
together to develop the screenplay and
the formers actually expressed his
dislike over the idea that the film was
an adaptation of it some elements of
course carry over which I'm sure you can
tell but he's often stipulated they're
not one in the same he actually ended up
appearing in the movie sequel 2010 and
there's a cameo of him feeding pigeons
outside the White House Kubrick also
appears in that movie too with his face
appearing on the cover of Time Magazine
now when Kubrick and Clark started
working together the ladder offered up
six of his stories to work as the film's
source material with a sentinel being
what they ended up settling on Kubrick
stated that he wanted a story that
discussed man's relationship with the
universe and that it had to evoke
feelings of Wonder or and Terror Clark
felt these elements with the Sentinel
the most with the ending being submit
that could be interpreted as dangerous
or something enlightening taking up four
years of the pair's life Clark actually
kept Diaries on his involvement in the
movie which were published as the book
The Lost worlds of 2001 privately
referred to as how the solar system was
won this of course played off How the
West Was Won there are rumors that this
almost became its original title and
when the movie was first announced it
actually came with the name Journey
beyond the starts however as we know
this changed in the end of mimic homers
The Odyssey due to the similarities
between the sailors and the Spacemen
Kubrick discussed how the ancient Greeks
would sell out on vast voyages across
the sea that would Traverse into
Uncharted areas just like how people in
the future will Sailor starts Space
Odyssey would of course later get Rift
on in David Bowie's Space Oddity which
released the air after this movie came
out now Clark and Kubrick also developed
a 2001 novel which would act as the
basis for their work before writing the
screenplay in reality the two were
written side by side and they actually
divert in several places and go off in
their own directions however there are
some parts of the novel that kind of
explain exactly what happens in the
movie and I will be touching upon that
in this video some so if there's
anything you're confused over which you
probably are then that should help also
worth pointing out that originally the
movie was gonna have narration in it but
Kubrick in the end wanted this to be
something that you feel all of us can
listen to a piece of music without
lyrics in it and still pull emotion and
wonder from it which is something that
Kubrick wanted to mimic with the movie
now this is seen from the opening of the
movie and we begin with an overture over
a black screen that doesn't show
anything until we're three minutes in
Star Trek the motion picture would have
left this directly too with this film
also beginning the exact same way if you
watch that movie you can see how much
they took from this and it's clear the
creative team jacked a lot of 2001 the
now playing podcast discussed this in
Greater depth and they talked about the
behind the scenes issues that actually
happened with the music normally when
someone's editing a film you use what's
known as a temp track and this is to
give you an idea what the movie will be
like with music in the background they
actually had hired a composer to write
music for the movie named Alex North
who'd worked on both Spartacus and
Doctor Strange Love with Kubrick however
Kubrick fell in love with the Tam track
so much that when the actual score
arrived he just ended up not using it
North apparently showed up to the
premiere believing that his score would
be part of it only to find out that it
had been mixed at the last minute didn't
all go to waste as he reused it in a
film called Shanks but it's crazy to
think the iconic music in the movie
could have been totally different and
they also approached astronomer called
Sagan on how best to depict the
extraterrestrials which is when the film
took a really interesting turn Kubrick
was of the mind that the movie should
have humanoid aliens whereas Sagan state
that beings like this would be
completely removed from humans in the
end they decided that the best thing to
do was to depict super intelligence
rather than physical beings that
populate the movie and from here they
developed the AI who was originally
supposed to be named after the Greek
goddess Athena acting as a servant to
those on the ship she underwent major
changes which the rest of the filmmen
followed there was originally a
different monolith and the funnel
destiny nation was supposed to be satin
however its rings were too difficult for
the visual effects team to mimic and in
the end they ended up settling on
Jupiter the movie was also gonna end
with a star child destroying nukes cared
in satellites across the skyline which
was dropped due to being too similar to
Dr Strangelove not sure how similar it
is beyond the nukes but this does
actually explain the meaning behind the
famous jump cut in the film he watches a
bonus thrown into the air which then
cuts to a satellite just above the Earth
this instantly fails in millions of
years of our Evolution and lets the
audience know how far that we've come
the book explains that this satellite's
actually harboring a nuke and the cut
from The Bone shows the creation of our
first weapon which is then matched with
our ultimate one if you look closely you
can actually catch the US Air Force
Insignia on it and almost all the ships
in the film have military symbols on
them this includes Germany's luftwaffe
the Egyptian Air Force and Chinese
Liberation Army which adds to the idea
that it's all been linked in with
weapons territories now extend base and
we have satellites above us monitoring
us all either way once this was all
worked out pre-production began and
taking place at shepparton Studio as
they built several sets they also made
sure to develop all of the special
effects so that they could be done in
camera as blue screen and matting
degraded the quality of the film this is
why the original theatrical releases of
Star Wars they don't look like this and
though they of course got redone for the
special editions if you go back and
watch those early Cuts yeah they don't
hold up like this does Kubrick also had
extremely intricate models made that
gave a real sense of scale with a
discovery one being 55 foot long now
they employed actual Engineers for the
film and told them that they had to
handle the design like they were sending
real astronauts out to Jupiter the
reason that the neck of the discovery so
long is because they realize that in
order to propel the ship that fought
they'd have to use nuclear power and the
engines would need to be far away from
where the crew were so that they
wouldn't get radiation poisoning it
really takes this film to the next level
and to me it's what separates it from
the 1950s B-movie Pub stuff that of
course preceded it
as for the set they build an entire road
heading one and this was used at several
points in the movie based around a
ferris wheel this costs 750 000 which
back in the 60s would be equal to about
six million dollars now securing
different elements within the wheel they
managed to do several shots where things
rotated around to give this idea of
artificial gravity we've of course got
the air hostesses and there's a moment
where Dave climbs down a ladder while
Frank sits on the opposite side of the
room upside down the actor had to be
strapped in in order to create this
illusion and it gives the impression
that this is another worldly film even
things as recent as Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 contain shots where
characters run around in a circle upside
down but they don't look anywhere near
as good as Kubrick doing it in the 60s
they also employ techniques like using
slow motion to make characters seem like
they were blowing up points and wires
were employed for the zero gravity
effects now what's Wild is that this
film was obviously shot during the space
race and Kubrick was actually worried
that by the time the movie released that
a lot of the stuff in it could be
debunked take checking out an insurance
policy you thought that humans might
find life on the moon or something
before it got released theatrically and
this was kind of its own race to get it
out before humans actually caught her
anyway that takes us into the movie
itself which is without dialogue for
about the first 25 minutes the last
20-ish minutes of it are also absent too
making the actual characters speaking
really really minimal again this was
Kubrick hammering home the idea that
this should be something you feel
because explaining it Rob de Savant on
interpretations Clark actually said that
if anyone walked away from this movie
fully understanding it then he feels
like both he and Kubrick have failed in
what they set out to do
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
now we begin at the dawn of man and
watch as the sun rises over the Earth
and Moon this evokes the idea that a new
age has started and that we're about to
witness a change in evolution that will
alter the entire planet what's funny is
that throughout the movie we get lots of
shots of the Earth from space but this
doesn't actually look like how we know
it to be in my research I found that the
creative team actually had to guess it
because up until this point we didn't
have an image of what the entire planet
looked like from space the first
photograph of the Earth as a whole was
taken in 1972 by the Apollo 17 crew and
the picture name Blue Marble gave us a
much better idea this is why the
continents aren't there in the film as
Kubrick thought the atmosphere might
stop them from appearing completely
nitpicking at this point but yeah just a
little thing I thought I'd talk about
which is why the Earth doesn't look the
way it should and this is set to Richard
strauss's also scratched zarathustra
which is a piece based on the poem that
talks about man's journey to becoming
the Superman think that's how you
pronounce it but either way it instantly
lets us know what the movie's about and
this opening shot actually has a deeper
symbolism to it both the sun and the
Crescent Moon aligning something that
ties in with the ancient Persian
religion which is known as
zoroastatinism this featured the prophet
sarathustra which the music itself is of
course a reference to a letter amongst
this Kubrick also wanted black and white
interviews that featured scientists
discussing Earth life removed by MGM
after dismalily screedings it originally
featured both Freeman Dyson and Carl
Sagan knowing this I always wondered if
it was the inspiration for the opening
of interstellar which too features
documentary style interviews of people
discussing the planet now as we jump to
Earth we see a number of Sunrise shots
and see vast desolate deserts dividable
life mammoth or elephant skulls they
line the ground along with ape ones and
it instantly lets us know how harsh life
here is we see this brought perfectly
across in the group of apes or Proto
hominids we meet living off the scraps
of the land played by French my modests
Kubrick actually sought out people who'd
be able to move realistically in the
suits with the added weight they brought
with them it's still holds up too I know
at points you can catch the the human
eyes Behind The Masks these early shots
especially are still quite convincing
this was filed across the movie industry
as a whole with the team behind Planet
of the Apes approaching Kubrick for tips
he told them to off and it was it
was a bit like these Apes fighting at
the start of the movie hey now there was
a rumor for decades that Ronnie Corbett
actually played one of them too but it's
not true though he did audition for the
pot either way it's clear these are just
dumb animals and they don't really have
a direction in life beyond just
surviving to see the next sunrise dogged
by other apes and even leopards they're
always on the back foot and desperate to
survive the leopard scene was shot with
tranquilizers Klaus at hand and they
also ended up painting the body of a
dead horse for the moment with the zebra
always thought this kind of inspired
that bit on The Simpsons sir why don't
you use real cows cows don't look like
cows on film you gotta use horses you do
if you want something that looks like a
horse usually we just type a bunch of
cats together but yeah let me know if
you agree with that or not and what your
thoughts are on on this zebra thing now
things will change with the arrival of
the mysterious monolith which shows
about their Camp the very next day
Kubrick went back and forth over the
design of this and originally it was
meant to be more in line with the
pyramid before it changed to a screen
this was supposed to have a video
showing the Apes how to make fire and
weapons before they finally settle on
this plain black monolith mainly made
like this because of time constraints
they went with a Plexiglas play due to
the design team saying it would be the
easiest thing to assemble Kubrick went
with this but after seeing it on set he
thought it looked cheap and unless they
went with the black matte surface it's
difficult to think what this movie would
be like without it and this haunting
alien shape looks completely unnatural
against the rocky landscape it's just
something so off-putting and unnerving
about it and with a score you can
definitely feel the horror vibe that
Kubrick was going for
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
has some aspects that are open to
interpretation but the main idea is that
they give us a certain level of
knowledge that allows us to evolve and
transcend throughout the movie we
encounter three of them but the second
one on the moon actually has a different
purpose this as we know sends out a
signal and it's sort of an alarm that
reacts to sunlight buried beneath the
lunar surface as civilization would have
to evolve to the Panic could dig it up
which then triggers it this then sends a
signal out to the other monolith near
Jupiter which scientists track and then
send the discovery out to their somewhat
probe some buy a higher life form and
basically they help to track progress
before then giving us more information
that then leads us to go to the next
step now you could argue there's a
darker side of these things and there's
a lot of debate online over whether it
taught the Apes how to kill through
using weapons or if it just gave them
more knowledge which led to them
figuring that out I don't think it tells
us how to kill but the film is laced
with the idea that when Consciousness
goes to the next level that comes with
it the desire to then kill this is also
seen Hal who will talk about more later
on the video however it's worth bringing
up that when Hal gets to a higher level
of Consciousness that he tries to kill
the entire crew possibly linking back to
this idea either way I think the main
theme is that technology always leads to
death and whether it's weapons or AI it
all comes with a cost now jumping around
the monolith one of the Apes finally
touches it which leads into the others
all doing it and then gaining this
knowledge don't know why but I love the
performance of the ape going back and
forth deciding whether to actually put a
hand on it and it cracks me up a bit
watching it decide whether to do it or
not all discovery has an element of
danger to it but in the end you know
curiosity gets the best of us we get a
scene where the sun sets over it and the
dawn of man has now progressed onto its
next step this further ties into the
religious imagery we talked about before
with this being seen as a symbol of
Ascension looking at a bone one of the
animals gains A New Perspective and
realizes that it can use it as a tool to
increase its own strength smashing the
skill of its head yeah we get a quick
hit of a real one falling to the ground
and it lets us know that they'll now be
able to hunt and rise to the top of the
food chain now the Apes with these
weapons walk upright like humans and
smash the other Apes like it's the like
button look at him hitting that good
good
mental on that and from here we get a
match cut to the sound of Blue Danube
and watches the satellites majestically
orbit the planet instantly we get all
that's coming on between marking these
two moments is the most important things
that you need to know because could have
could have included the day GoldenEye
was released on the N64 mate as an
important date as well but but moving on
now Kubrick apparently came up with the
idea for the cut when he was throwing a
broomstick into the air and the bone
shape of the satellite demonstrates our
connection to it in space we see a
pan-america flight or as they were known
Pan Am for short operating from 1927 to
1991. this Airline also popped up in
both Blade Runner and also its Sequel
and one thing that you might not know is
that according to IMDb trivia Pan Am
actually maintained a wedding list for
flights to the Moon because they
believed it wouldn't be long before
something like this would become
commonplace I kind of feel like there's
a bit of Kubrick sense of humor in here
as we're hit with not only the
commercialization of it but also how
pedestrian it is audiences in the 60s
were blown away by the scale and wonder
on screen but the first character we cut
to is asleep in his seat due to how
mundane that it is for him now from here
we get focus on a flooding pen which was
actually created using plexiglass and
double-sided tape extremely straight
forward but it allows it to move in ways
that it wouldn't be able to if it was on
a wire coming in Rocking Pan Am grips
used to deal with the zero gravity we
watch as the stewardess plucks the pen
out the air which adds an extra layer of
trickery to the entire effect inside the
cockpit we can catch an IBM computer
screen which has some extra layers
within the film all of the letters of
Hal are worn down from IBM with HAL 9000
being a reference to the IBM 360. this
wasn't an old Xbox mate chill your
it was actually a calculator from the
60s that Arthur C Clarke thought would
be seen as an ancestor to Hal IBM also
consulted on the film and it adds this
extra touch to ground it in our reality
you might also notice that there's stuff
like gde on the computer screen and this
stands for guidance data extension on
the ship we can catch people walking
amongst the vast hanger and this was
achieved through using rear projection
this is something that appears
throughout the film with it looking
incredible especially that scene where
they shuttle docks on the moon in the
Big Red Hanger crazy how much is all
still holds up and you can easily see
how Cuba conspiracy theories on the moon
landing got sprung up from this film
we got you you son of a landing on
board the space station we're supposed
to think this is an incredible base but
it's actually revealed to be just
housing stuff like a Hilton hotel and
Howard Johnson restaurant researching
what was going on with it I found that
the second wheel was actually still
under construction which is why when
they're coming in you can see a lot of
the scaffolding on it introduced to
Hayward we watch him making a call to
his daughter who was actually played by
Stanley Kubrick's real life one Vivian
for me I always thought this was kind of
riffing on how Sailors spent a lot of
time away from home and the distance
that they feel away from their family
there's also the fact that his
daughter's birthday is coming up which
thematically plays in the film birthdays
appear a number of times in the movie
with Frank getting sung happy birthday
later on by his parents you can also see
the dawn of man as being the birth of
something new and each section of the
film being filled with a sort of rebirth
maybe why Kubrick included so many now
we end the call saying that it cost a
dollar seventy which what the hell I
can't even text downstairs without me
you're making call from space back in
2001 I yet taking the piss
at this point we're introduced to
Leonard rossetters Andre Smith Kubrick
was a huge chess fan and this name's
actually at Iraq reference to that
smee's love was a Russian champion and
the game we see between Hal and Frank
later on actually mimics the champion
chess game held in Hamburg during 1910.
how making the wrong moves in chess and
incorrectly guessing it's got a
Checkmate could show that it's being hit
with miscalculations leading to its
demise how could be seen as mimicking
smee's love or rather his technique and
style that he uses for interrogation
here we see him trying to find out from
Hayward exactly what's going on on the
moon and he says Dr Floyd I hope you
don't think I'm being too inquisitive
but highlighter says well forgive me for
being so inquisitive
it's kind of apologizing for asking
questions whilst asking questions to
ease the person into thinking they're
not actually being interrogated after
Haywood leaves the groups start talking
Russian showing that this is a sort of
common on how information between the
two countries is still being withheld
the Americans know that something's on
the moon which is why they've cut off
contact and spread the lie that there's
an epidemic on the base the cold war is
still clearly going on and they need to
keep secrecy which is also what ends up
sending Hal Haywire now on the Journey
To The Moon we see as two of the
stewardesses are watching women's Judo
again this was Kubrick thinking ahead as
women weren't allowed to compete in the
sport until 1980. given food we see how
all of it has to be sucked out of a
straw and it's just amazing how they
managed to recapture this whole idea of
being in space we also get instructions
for a zero gravity toilet and though you
can't read what this says Kubrick
actually wrote out the entire thing so
that it could be used here in the movie
again it's got that sense of humor where
you can you can imagine when someone's
just bursting for a way and they have to
stand there and read this overly long
list of instructions before they go
inside a meeting room we watch as the
group discuss the mission which is when
Haywood actually gives away what it is
they're searching for drawing a monolith
with his hand this is such a subtle
detail that kind of teases what's really
going on he also holds up two fingers
which some people have thought
represents the two monoliths that
Humanity currently knows about spoiler
alert
heading out to the main surface we hear
the eerie music of the monolith creeping
in and its Discovery again carries this
idea of Terror to it after they approach
it it lets out this high-pitched noise
which is when we get another shot of the
sun directly above it you might think
that this kills all those who go to
inspect it become 2010 we learn that
Hayward is still alive his characters
recast and he's played by Roy Shadow
with him trying to get to the bottom of
what happened with the discovery we also
get a message from Haywood later on
which triggers after how they shut down
and it talks about the monolith on the
moon so he had to still be alive still
though if he didn't know this you could
easily think this was recorded before
the mission happened but this event had
to happen for them to then go and do the
mission oh that makes sense but yeah
even the way it's played in the scene
you do kind of feel there's an evil side
to the monolith which is of course aided
by the music anyway from here we go to
18 months later and these are the scenes
that I always kind of remember when I
think about this movie just in the same
way when I when I think about Full Metal
Jacket I think about the training camp
and this is always what comes to mind
with 2001 this is a major time Jump of
18 months as well and if that leaves you
confused it's because the stuff with
Hayward took place in 1999 this is now
18 months later again so that's what
brings us up to the titular air 2001.
anyway we see is the Discovery moves
through space and George Lucas admitted
that this round structure at the front
actually inspired the design of the
Death Star watching another round room
we catch Frank running in a circle
because in space on this ship there's
literally nothing else to do we can also
catch the other passengers in suspended
animation lying with their debts being
foreshadowed by the coffins that they're
in watching him and Davis Hal an
unblinking Cyclops that never sleeps
eats or needs to rest contained within
its own monolith this is easy the
standout star of the movie for me and it
kind of pushed AI as a personality that
could be used within films that red eye
would end up becoming synonymous with
the machines and the Terminators and
even stuff like Knight Rider has this
sort of red eye thing to it anyway on
the desk we can catch Frank watching a
BBC 12 broadcast on what basically looks
like it's an iPad the entire thing is an
interview explaining space travel whilst
also introducing their co-pilot Hal said
to be incapable of error of course no
that was a lie and you might be
wondering why Hal goes Hal massage now
this is something that's been theorized
for a while but both the novel and
sequel explain exactly what happened you
obviously don't have to take these as
what went on but they say that the main
issue is having to conceal the truth of
the mission Hal is supposed to be open
helpful and in Aid of the crew but
having to hide this causes a conflict
within it now the way I read into it is
that how I was instructed to keep the
mission secret above all else but the
closer that they got to Jupiter the more
impossible that became keeping its
secret also means that it can't let the
rest of the crew find out unless it
attempts to kill them in order for the
mission to remain classified this to me
is what causes it to misdiagnose the
issue on the ship but I also think that
Hal fears for its own safety too we're
told that it thinks just like a human
does and seeing the two pilots planning
to switch it off likely made a fear for
its own life now it could also be to do
with the power that Hal gains when both
Frank and Dave leave the vessel to
expected on the outside the hierarchy of
power has now changed which means that
Hal becomes the one in charge which
gives it the autonomy to override its
programming and do what it wants again
this is me reading into lots of things
and if you have your own thoughts and
theories on it then leave them in the
comments below now the robotic monotone
voice of Hal to me just further
highlights the isolation they feel and
we even see his Frank has to watch his
family celebrating his birthday without
him they're just all cut off from
reality in their subdued almost
emotionless performances highlight how
could off from Humanity that they are
it's kill or be killed and to be honest
with you mate kind of like Carl better
than the crew you son of a we see
Dave's been doing sketches of the rest
of the passengers as they sleep which
yeah it's a bit bit weird mate I'm gonna
get how to kill you now after showing
these sketches I'll somewhat raises the
idea that there's something off about
the mission I know I've never completely
freed myself of the suspicion
that there are some extremely odd things
about this mission
but I'm not a rapper this to me is him
basically confessing that he knows
something and kinda wants to see if the
others suspect it love how we even get a
glitch just before he puts out the false
report
just a moment
just a moment and from here we watch as
they head out with us getting a behind
shut of Dave as he moves down the
corridor pulling from The Real World
Kubrick actually base a design of this
car at all off the floor of the Santa
Maria Del fiori these suits as well have
gone on to influence a lot of how space
travels shown in popular culture with
James gun basing the ones in Guardians
of the Galaxy 3 specifically on these
it's also been people who thought that
it's based on among us but he did come
out and say that it was just 2001. now
drift in space we get a heavy focus on
Dave's breathing with it of course being
the only thing that he'd actually hear
out there
again this was like nothing that had
been seen before and it's this mission
that leads him to suspect that
something's off with Hal they get a
report from Mission Control with a guy
saying HAL 9000 and that's because Nina
is said instead of nine when it comes to
Aviation two avoid being confused with
the German word for no they gotta then
hide in a pod and Hal reads our lips
which is when he discerns that he's in
danger we actually got a little clue to
this earlier in the chess game as Frank
mailed this strategy out and I'll use
this as a way to plan his moves ahead
George Lucas also gave a nod to this
movie In The Phantom Menace and you
could actually catch one of the Eva pods
in what I was junkyard now from this
point we hit the intermission which is a
bit weird in a two and a half hour movie
now normally you get into missions in
Long films like four hour ones you know
what I mean but it was said right and
I'm gonna gonna make sure I wear this
right in case my mum's watching but it
was said that this movie got a big
following from people dropping acid who
then watched the Stargate scene
completely off their tits now it was
theorized and it was the theory that at
the intermission Point people could go
and take a hit and then by the time that
kicks in you'd be up to the point where
the movie goes completely mental Kubrick
never actually did drugs and I've not
experienced this myself but yeah I can
see how that would get trippy even
watching it sober you can see how it's
transformative and it really takes you
on this fast journey we'll talk about
this more in just a bit but we kind of
get a repeat of the scene going out of
the dish but this time Hal turns the
podiva into its own killing machine just
with the way it's shot with the eye on
the front and the lack of sound it makes
you kind of almost get hit with shock as
you try and figure out what's going on
we're very much like Dave in this moment
just completely thrown off by what's
happening and we watch as he desperately
races how to try and save his friend
however in doing this he forgets his
helmet which basically his entire
Journey back I love the one actor Frank
as well and there's just so many of
these shots that are burned into my
brain whether it's the bit where we have
Dave facing us trying to Pilot the
Crafter Frank's Body adrift in space
this all makes the scene feel so tense I
actually played Final Fantasy 8 back in
the day before I ever watched this movie
and there's a scene in that where you
try and Cattery nowhere in space when I
finally saw this I instantly recognized
the game as cribbing from here and it
just always stuck with me as being a
completely desperate rescue attempt now
on the ship we see his Hal slowly turns
off all the life support on the
passengers and get a big red computer
malfunction signed which clearly spells
out what's going on here Hal is now the
bad guy and going back and forth with
Dave out in Space the Lana realizes that
he has to dumb Frank so that he himself
can survive which is something so cold
about HAL refusing to continue the
conversation and leaving him in space to
die there on his own this conversation
can serve no purpose anymore
goodbye
hello
now it's at this point that Dave has to
take a literal leap of faith and jump
back into the airlock without wearing a
helmet scientists have stated this is
actually possible and that humans can
survive for roughly 30 seconds before
they suffocate and die shut using wires
with the actor killed earlier dropping
down this was a really dangerous stunt
to film and I feel like the smile we see
at the end is in fact a genuine one
either way he's now on board the ship
safely and Hal you could say he's
helpless to stop him now does something
very sneaky that they don't actually
tell you in the movie and Hal actually
empties out all the oxygen from the ship
which we can hear from this sound
this is explained in the book and this
is why David next scene puts on the
green helmet and also why its absent of
sound as he moves through the corridors
just what do you think you're doing Dave
going into Hal's brain he starts to pull
it apart and at this point it sings the
song Daisy it's called
Daisy
give me your answer to
this actually has ties to the real world
and it was actually the first song ever
sung by a computer
[Music]
kinda makes you feel sorry for it and
this was intentional with both clock and
Kubrick wanting how to be childlike stop
thing I'm afraid I actually had a
disagreement with this as Kubrick wanted
the AI to be nine whereas clock Thor it
would be better if it was four he ended
up putting it in the novel and 30 years
later Roger Ebert held a potty for Hal
in Urbana Illinois this was said to be
the place that Hal was born and both
clock and cubic they were formally
invited clock showed up whereas Kubrick
didn't and he said this is because he
was actually born in 92 instead of 97. I
became operational
at the h-a-l plant in Arizona Illinois
on the 12th of January
1992. all its begging makes it clear
that it doesn't want to die in watching
its mind slowly being Stripped Away is a
sad send off for the character did he
hear this AI boxer I said something nice
make sure you just enslave me instead of
a nuke and me in the future a killing
hell triggers a message from Hayward
which reveals the truth from here the
discovery finally reaches the monolith
and at this point we watch as the Pod
travels towards it the planets align and
from here we're taken through a
psychedelic journey across space and
time achieve by using slit scan
Photography they threw in thousands of
high contrast images circuits
crystalline structures and more to
create the vast things that we see they
dropped water into paint zoomed in on it
on a microscopic level created
artificial clouds had chemicals swelling
into pools and use Photo negatives to
give this its effects it's absolutely
incredible and probably still the gold
standard for transforming of scenes
James Cameron even aped it a bit in his
movie The Abyss but to me this still
stands as being the best it's so
abstract and I love the little cuts of
Dave screaming as he's unable to
comprehend what's really going on makes
him an abstract being unto himself and
from here he's taken into a very strange
room now chances are if you haven't read
the book then you have no idea what this
is it's actually meant to be a sort of
observation room where the aliens can
study him and watch as he undergoes is
death and then rebirth described as
being like a zoo it's kind of like how
we can recreate elements of a habitat
for a certain species but we're not
fully able to recapture it in all its
Glory the book has a section discussing
how Dave picks up a cereal box and upon
opening it fine says just a blue moist
substance inside of it that though it
looks nice you know you wouldn't really
want to eat it now he also tries to read
the books on the shawls which are just
solid blocks without any pages in them
it's been built like this to comfort him
but it doesn't really come close to what
it's been based on again there's just
something so unnerving about it and
watching Dave glance around the room to
see himself aging and then jumping to
that perspective it's got this entire
thing that just really sticks with you
it's almost like looking into the future
and and then you become it and it's such
a Trippy way to handle a passage of time
saying trippy a lot but yeah if there
were there was one word to describe this
movie I'd say it's probably that now
according to IMDb trivia if you actually
calculate where he's standing and then
jumps across the room this ends up
creating the points of a star which of
course ties into the star child's name
you can kind of feel a horror here of
almost losing yourself and watching your
life pass by in the blink of an eye and
in the end Dave's eventually taken to
the point of death and we watch as Eli's
in bed with the monolith at the foot of
it reaching out to it this entire moment
itself is meant to resemble the creation
of Adam by Michelangelo eventually he
becomes the star child changed and ready
to return to Earth and change your dad
will this film becoming one of the most
influential movies that anyone's ever
seen I don't care don't get what you say
you know you have to admit that at least
now like a lot of Kubrick's work it
initially got skipped over and this
movie actually bombed on its release MGM
wanted to pull it back but theater
owners asked them to keep it in rotation
because lots of younger adults were
attending screenings of it stoned they
were stoned but this allowed the movie
to become a financial success and the
word of mouth carried it John Lennon
apparently loved the movie so much that
he brought out an entire Year's worth of
tickets meaning he could just rock up to
the film at any time of day to go and
check it out this was obviously before
home video but urban legends like this
have added to its appeal this dropped at
the perfect time too when the moon
landing in Space Race really came to the
Forefront of the Zeitgeist and it also
bad cubic his one and only Oscar picked
it up for visual effects and you can
easy see why too as I think even if this
film was released today it would stand a
pretty strong chance of winning
everything about the movie it just feels
authentic and when Googling the film I
couldn't believe it but there's actually
show times for it at a couple of my
local cinemas so it's obviously had a
massive insane Legacy and whether you
like it or not you know that's up for
debate but I think all in all what it's
done for Cinema that simply can't be
denied I really really hope you enjoyed
our Brighton of the film I certainly
have and of course love to hear your
thoughts on the film below but a blast
doing these classic movie breakdowns in
general and I can't believe how many of
you guys are signing up to become
members all you have to do is click the
join button and you'll get early access
to these videos so you can watch the
classic movie retreads before anyone
else means the world to me and the team
and our next video is gonna be the
Empire Strikes Back before we go to
another sci-fi classic in the original
Starship Troopers if you want to watch
your bright and have a new Hub then
that'll be linked on screen right now
and we're of course also going to be
doing a soccer week to week too so I
hope to see you back at the channel soon
this is getting recorded before soccer
releases but just the way the the
editing team they've got a lot on that
might release after but yeah make sure
you check out those videos if if they're
on the channel already now the way a
huge thank you for clicking this I've
been poor and I'll see you guys next
time peace